[Music]
great to see you guys thank you for
doing this it's good to be here we
should take some of you and the work
that you're doing I'm very exciting
you're at the book coming out soon so
you're making rounds yes sir I
appreciate you taking time out to talk
to me about all the stuff that you guys
are up to it's cool and Cyrus you you
live in Costa Rica that's right yeah
I've been in Costa Rica two years what
is the deal with that so my wife and I
went to Costa Rica for our honeymoon
and while we were there we had just
sounded like this idea that like maybe
it would be fun to live outside the
United States one day uh-huh and then
when we started talking with people we
got introduced this whole network of
expats that live there and the
overwhelming feeling from the expats
that we had talked to were like if you
don't move here you're making a big
mistake
and we were like wow people so holy
that's such strong conviction about this
right and we made a real estate agent
and he said oh you could live over here
on the beach and here's a condo here's
the house here's up on the hill you name
it and it was very affordable so we
can't meet each other we were like
should we do this
well back to San Francisco where we were
living at the time about a month set-in
or so and we had like you know the
desire to move there was like very
strong and then it kind of started
waning over time of course so you know
it's June we wake up one morning and
it's cold it's windy it's foggy and I
think it's raining and everywhere else
on the planet is warm right except the
little like 7 by 7 city of San Francisco
there's great summers and San Francisco
so my wife wakes up and she looks at me
she's like can I ask you a question I
was like why she goes what are we doing
here and I was like I don't know let's
go
so within a couple of weeks we had
bought two one-way plane tickets she'd
resigned from her job working as a nurse
manager at Kaiser and then we basically
just like packed up our bags sold all
our stuff and moved on Costa Rica that's
a bold move very bold move yeah and
after two years I mean do you feel do
you I mean do you come back here
frequently or do you feel like I would
my sense is that I would start to feel
kind of detached like you know a little
bit isolated but maybe that's not I mean
if you're surrounded by an amazing
community I mean living and doing what
you do kind of online and all that kind
of stuff you can do what you do anywhere
I suppose right yeah for sure yeah so
because we can do video conferencing and
we can do podcast and you name it
and I can interact with Robbie and the
team every single day all day long
uh-huh it's great you know the Internet
is like more powerful today than it's
ever been and so as a result of that you
don't really feel isolated but then you
know aside from being on the computer
all day long there's a whole collection
of people that are from the United
States that move down there plus there's
a whole bunch of Tico's that I become
friends with I'm on a soccer team there
I got a CrossFit gym you name it so
right we're like integrated into this
into the community which is great
what part of Costa Rica we're in you
know what Tamarindo is money chance yeah
that's like the big surf beach yeah I've
been there so it's like west coast on
the north yeah and then we're like
another 20 minutes north of there oh
cool yeah so I know that area yeah you
have to been there I've been there yeah
one time one time yeah do you like it I
did yeah I wasn't there as long as I
would have liked to have like sort of
explore the area but I did go to that
one beach mm-hmm
yeah yeah the whole area is really nice
and you know the town that we live in
has on a good day a thousand people you
know and it's there's there something
that's actually what we like about it so
much is that it's real simple and that's
the main reason why we moved out there
we were just looking for simplicity yeah
you know and like I think there's sort
of there's many people you probably
yourself included where you're sort of
like a certain point you're just sort of
like I don't I don't really want things
and I don't want all this sex stuff
around me I just want to like live in a
nice place that's just like close to the
beach I want to hear the monkeys in the
morning and I want to hang out with my
cats like is that okay yes you know to
me you're like a 65 year old man it's
beautiful I can confirm is retreats yeah
that's great
do you go down there yeah for the rhone
retreats and visit and I told them like
the Internet connections got to be good
if internet connection is good that was
the condition and Robbie I was trying to
remember when we first met I mean I
think it was almost 10 years ago going
over to Brian windows for lunch yeah
lunch with you he's really like 2009 or
something like yeah and we even met I
believe was before that of one of the
veg fests before you even launched the
podcast and everything yeah yeah yeah I
remember people say hey that guy he's an
incredible athlete I check him out yeah
you you I mean you cut your teeth at
forks over knives or going out on your
own so it's cool man
and it's this is a this is a holy
alliance between the two of you guys you
guys are doing powerful stuff so let's
get into it I mean I think that the the
best place to kind of launch into this
is is for both of you guys to share your
own personal story with diabetes type 1
diabetes if you're both you're both T 1
and you both have pretty fascinating
kind of histories around that that's
right I don't know who wants to start
who wants to start with roshambo ok so I
grew up in Palo Alto California two
parallel to high right I went to Palo
too high and then went to Stanford as
well just like you and my age what year
did you graduate 89 you're not even in
high school yet I was you're right I was
I was in fifth grade right yeah all
right so I'm just a few years younger so
I went to palliative high and then you
know when I was at Stanford senior year
in college trying to graduate move on
with my life and all of a sudden I get
diagnosed with type 1 diabetes and I
didn't know anything about diabetes at
that time so all I remember feeling
before I even knew what diabetes was was
I was trying to study for finals and I
was extremely low energy my thirst was
unbelievable and I just couldn't
concentrate very well and as a result of
drinking you know one gallon one and a
half two gallons of water a day just
kind of out of the blue I was urinating
all the time so I would go to the
bathroom like clockwork every 30 minutes
so I picked up the phone and called my
sister after like 48 hours of going
through this and she's a Doctor of
Osteopathy and I said hey Shahnaz here's
my symptoms what is happening to me and
she's normally pretty calm under
pressure and she just she just lost it
she just started crying right away she
was like please just drop everything
you're doing go to the hospital right
now or go to the health center
and I was like why what's happening and
she's like you you have type 1 diabetes
and that's what you're explaining to me
and I was like Shahnaz come on I don't
have diabetes don't be silly don't be
you know how can that be possible I'm
like I'm normal weight I exercise I
think I eat well and she's like you
don't understand at that time I
literally thought that diabetes has
something to do with old people
and cake
that's literally all I thought about
right and so I was like alright let me
go to the health center show up at the
health center half an hour later test my
blood glucose and it's 600 a little
higher than 600 so for a normal range we
were just talking about this because you
just tested in you were at 77 normal
matches between 70 and 130 70 130
exactly that's what's considered so sort
of like you know normal range so if we
tested your blood glucose at any moment
in time either before a meal or after a
meal you would likely be within that 70
to 130 range and that's good because
you're sort of your pancreas and liver
or making sure that you stay in that
physiologically normal range I was six
times higher than that and so at that
point I was like wow I don't really
understand what's happening they took me
the hospital they started giving me an
IV of saline in one arm IV of insulin in
the other arm and over a 24-hour period
they monitored my blood glucose by
giving me insulin and they dropped my
blood glucose to a safe level and then
they discharged me so while I was in the
hospital they pieced together my health
history that I wasn't able to do before
that and they said hey by the way you
don't have you have not one not two but
three autoimmune conditions and I was
like wait well huh and they said yeah
you have Hashimoto's hypothyroidism
which had set in six months prior
you also have alopecia universalis which
is why I have no hair no eyebrows did
you have no hair at that time I was
losing my hair at that time to be
confusing extremely confusing I mean I
remember I was seeing pictures it was up
for sure when she hauled your sister
like something's not right my hair's
falling out exactly right but eyebrows
are yeah bald patches in the back of my
head and then it kind of like spread to
the front of my head and a little bit on
my like chest hair as well but the
doctors at that time before they can't
arrive at the conclusion that it was
alopecia were treating me for ringworm
and so they were giving me steroid
injections directly into my head
thinking that if they if they did that
it would stimulate hair growth and I
went for some of those injections and my
god was it painful so they said okay you
have Hashimoto's hypothyroidism alopecia
universalis and then number three type
one diabetes by the way we've never seen
anybody with this combination of
autoimmune conditions ever before you
have what's called a poly glandular
Ottowa
syndrome can we talk about you at our
next huddle and I was like the okay so
they didn't really instill me with much
confidence mm-hmm and they were being
honest with me and that's all I could
ask right so what have you learned sorry
to interject like what have you learned
in the years since about the
relationship between those three things
like what what kind of confluence of
events or what was happening
biomechanically inside of you that led
to all three of those manifesting at the
same time yeah it's a great question
actually so as far as alopecia
universalis is concerned I haven't I
haven't found too strong of a sort of
like dietary connection or like what
could actually trigger that but there is
a strong axis between Hashimoto's
hypothyroidism type 1 diabetes and
celiacs disease so patients that present
with one often can present with another
but in that group and so there's a lot
of people that we know who are living
with type 1 diabetes as well as
Hashimoto's hypothyroidism and that
seems to be a really common occurrence
some of it could be died induced some of
it can be induced by a virus some of it
can be induced by potential pathogens
inside of food and so there's there's a
whole collection like the the the type 1
diabetes research base is constantly
searching for us an answer it's like
what causes type 1 diabetes what and and
there's there's some strong evidence
that there's multiple environmental
triggers but there's really no smoking
gun at this point and I don't I don't
necessarily know there ever will be
right point being they give me this
diagnosis of 3 they discharge me from
the hospital blood glucose meter two
types of insulin test strips
carbohydrate counting guide a life alert
bracelet and about a box of syringes and
they're like see you later and as far as
the hair is concerned just forget about
it yeah I did have a friend who I was
eating dinner with him at some point
around that time and he was like hey
Cyrus no offense but your hair looks
weird I got you I got you
and he's like here's what we gonna do
we're gonna finish dinner we're gonna
drive to the store I'm gonna get a big
razor that's what I was gonna ask you
guys decide to shave it yeah
and he was like I'm just gonna get rid
of your hair tonight and I was like game
so there's a few people that can wear it
as well as rocket well I appreciate it
but see at the time I didn't know right
because I had hair and I was like get
rid of this is a gamble right so get
discharged and you know like I had all
those physical you know medical
electronic devices plus insulin syringes
test trips you name it and then what I
didn't expect was that I was going to
also be discharged with a bunch of fear
so I go return to my normal life you
know I have like six months left to
school and I'm like I don't know what to
do I literally don't know what to do I
don't know what to eat I don't know what
to exercise I don't know how much
insulin to give myself this is literally
just like a guess and check game I guess
they didn't give you any sort of
counseling or somebody who could help
kind of you know mentor you through that
aspect of it they gave me some light
recommendations and they they have this
sort of you know inject this much
insulin if your blood glucose was doing
this it's called a sliding scale you
know and it's like it's like a
generalized set of recommendations that
are all based off of you know what use
your glucose right now and it's just
like it's just it's just not that
helpful let's put it that way
right and so I got that plus I also got
this idea of like you should eat a low
carbohydrate diet and I was like why
would I do that they said well when you
eat more carbohydrates your blood
glucose will go up and your insulin use
will go up so a simple way to not have
that happen is to reduce your
carbohydrate intake and then you can
keep your glucose controlled and you can
keep your insulin controlled and I said
cool sounds good so I started eating a
lower carbohydrate diet more turkey
burgers for breakfast eggs black forest
ham sandwiches for lunch with you know
small amount of bread I'd have some fish
for dinner small amounts of rice and I
was just really trying to focus on like
eating more fat and protein rich foods
and eating less carbohydrates what my
doctor told me so for the first year of
my life with diabetes supposed to make
my glucose more controllable it didn't
not at all my blood glucose meter which
you would saw me using just before this
right
what it does is you to use it every day
multiple times a day and it's it's an
indicator of whether where your glucose
is so you can use that to make decisions
and so what was supposed to happen is my
glucose was supposed to stay within that
80 to 130 range for majority of the day
and if it goes higher comes low I can do
something about it but on a given day
Michael cosas was 40 210 120 280 64 just
bouncing up down up down up down random
number generator literally a random
number generator and when you're dealing
with if you I don't know if you've ever
you've probably never experienced a
glucose higher than like 140 or 160 as
my guess because your non diabetic and
that's a good thing but when your blood
glucose goes high it feels terrible
it feels really terrible what it what is
that experience so for me I feels like
it feels like my head is a balloon like
it's kind of expanded and it's very
large I get a taste of metal inside my
mouth and my nose starts to feel like
it's it's larger than it really is and
it just kind of feels like my head is
swelling it's got a lot of pressure
inside of it and I get really thirsty
when your glucose is low or when my
glucose is low you get the opposite
which is it is sort of that you
basically your brain is sort of being
starved for glucose temporarily and so
it leads to shaky hands some slurred
speech sometimes you see little like
black spots in your vision you can get
this diaphoretic sweating and it's just
kind of this like panic mode and also in
your appetite increases and you want to
eat everything that you can see so you
know bouncing between hypo hyperglycemia
and hypoglycemia on a daily basis just
like it sucks all the mental energy out
of right it just takes away and you must
been thinking that well I just need to
perfect how I'm doing this right like
clearly like I'm just I'm an amateur and
if I can just figure out you know if I
can read the signals of my body right
and regulate my insulin intake and pay
more attention to when I'm eating and
what I'm eating that I can get this like
dialed in
exactly right and like I I was trained
as an engineer as a mechanical engineer
in college and you know that training
basically teaches you how to control
very complex systems that have multiple
moving parts right you know into
something that's very controlled you got
spreadsheets out
I've gotta figure this out like come on
this is not there's not that many
variables let's control this and this is
literally the one system I could not
control again I didn't have a degree in
biology I didn't really know that much
but I figured I could try and control
the system and why was I wrong so it all
kind of came to a tipping point one day
I had gone to work in the morning I had
played a game of soccer at lunch for an
hour I had worked out in the morning
before work I had eaten a low
carbohydrate diet and then I got home at
like 5 o'clock p.m. to go to to eat
dinner so I checked my blood glucose in
preparation for eating dinner and I was
hoping that it would be in range
give me a 120 I 130 than that I can
inject a normal amount of insulin go eat
my dinner and go to sleep I checked my
glucose and it was like 288 and I got so
frustrated because again I was doing
everything that I was supposed to do and
so I just got I just got filled with
this just anxious rage and I just picked
up my glucose meter and I just threw it
across the room and it just hit the wall
and shattered and then I just sunk into
the couch and I just started crying and
I was just like I was so frustrated that
I couldn't figure this out and it was in
that moment where I literally heard a
voice inside of my head and the voice
said Cyrus just learned how to eat you
don't know anything about nutrition
learn how to eat and your life will
fundamentally change for the better and
I was like ok this is this is my calling
this is me message from God literally
yeah and you're like and I probably
should get a new glucose meter exactly
so the next day I basically started
looking for more information I started
getting recipe books I started you know
viewing videos online and talking to
people one thing led to another and I
got introduced to this guy named Doug
Graham so Doug Graham when I met him he
basically was the only person I knew
that was confident and talking to a
person with type 1 diabetes because type
1 diabetes is considered like a like
dangerous enough condition or like a
nuanced enough condition that most
health practitioners you know sort of
like like I
I don't really know how to handle
insulin it's kind of dangerous but Doug
was like listen come under my wing I'll
show you exactly what to do so I go to a
retreat that he's hosting and under his
guidance he basically says listen I'm
gonna transition you to a diet that's
basically lots of fruit lots of
vegetables and we're gonna temporarily
while you're here we're gonna give up
meat cheese chicken fish and high-fat
foods in general I said okay great let's
do this
and he said your glucose is gonna become
a lot more controllable but I want you
to feel it so over the course of that
seven days what happened to my blood
glucose was mind-blowing
absolutely mind-blowing I went into it
with again really highly variable blood
glucose a lot of insulin use in the
first 24 hours of being there my blood
glucose fell so dramatically that I hit
six hypoglycemia is five to six
hypoglycemia back to back to back to
back and I was like I hadn't felt that
in a long time as a result of that I had
to start backing off on the amount of
insulin I was dosing myself and then
that got better by day two by day three
by day four by the time day seven had
rolled around I had cut my insulin use
by thirty five to forty percent and the
kicker and this whole thing was that it
wasn't I wasn't calorie restricting I
wasn't I wasn't not eating food in order
to reduce my insulin use on the contrary
I was eating more food than I'd ever
eaten before and I was eating more
carbohydrates food than I'd ever eat
before more fruits more vegetables I
mean I kid you not I was eating plates
with like six to eight bananas on them
with persimmons and grapes and papayas
and mangoes and I was like how is it
that I'm eating all this food but I'm
using less insulin that doesn't make
sense and it kind of put this in context
first of all you know Doug Graham widely
known for for being a proponent of what
he calls the 80/10/10 diet what ratio of
macros 80% carbohydrates 10% fat 10%
protein and this you know in in terms of
type 1 diabetes this is anathema like
you this contravenes the medical
establishment or the point of view that
somebody with your condition should be
eating a
carbohydrate diet instead he's putting
you on this very high carbohydrate
regimen which basically flies in the
face of everything that you've been told
exactly right so the conventional wisdom
would be that if you're eating this much
fruit that this is gonna make your your
blood glucose skyrocket and make this
more difficult to control and acquire
more insulin yes yeah so my insulin have
been creeping and and so it you know
just to put a pin in it that the the
experience that you had was was
diametrically opposed to that was the
opposite exactly right so yeah my
insulin use had been increasing over the
course of time from the time I was first
diagnosed I was using like mid 20s and
then it became 32 36 37 41 43 there were
times where I was injecting 45 to 50
units of insulin per day on this low
carbohydrate diet and now I'm faced with
the prospect of eating up boatloads of
fruit and I'm doing some mental math on
my own 50 is gonna turn into seven he's
gonna turn into 120 that seems like a
lot of insulin but instead 50 turned
into 26 27 32 units are in sanh per day
yeah and we're gonna talk about why that
is we're gonna get into the weeds on
that geeked-out and I but I also think
it's worth mentioning like Doug Graham
you know he's not without controversy
himself versus guys like you know he's
gotten into trouble with these fasting
retreats and you know people going a
little bit too far with this stuff right
yeah to be clear you know we're not
advocating that exact approach in what
we've written in the book and the
science we're citing it's it's different
he's kind of like sparked our journey
right yeah I got it I got it yeah to
give Doug the credit that he's do Doug
fundamentally changed my life no
questions asked and like you know if it
wasn't for Doug I wouldn't have been
introduced to this at that point in my
life and it wouldn't have like allowed
me to start changing my life for the
better and then going on to learn more
about it so I gotta give him the credit
writings do and as an engineer this must
have blown your mind a little bit a
hundred percent it was fascinating to me
so I leave this retreat I was so
fascinated by what I learned that I just
went straight to the books and I just
started reading everything I possibly
could
started accessing the literature reading
text books you name it then I enrolled
in
school to go learn organic chemistry
biochemistry nutritional biochemistry
and then at a certain point I said you
know what I think I want to actually get
a PhD degree in this so I applied to
schools I got into UC Berkeley and then
I was there for five years to learn
nutritional biochemistry so that I could
I could talk science about my own
personal experience but the motivation
to get your PhD was was fueled entirely
by your own experience fueled entirely
about my own experience but but it was
to ask a bigger question and the
question was am i a freak of nature
that's literally what I wanted to learn
because if this was something that only
applied to me and I was just some really
interesting and of one experiment okay
fine I get it but if if what I was
experiencing could also be applied to
other people living with type 1 or
pre-diabetes or type 2 now you have a
much bigger story right and so while I
was at school I started to understand
the science of blood glucose control and
diabetes and insulin resistance and
while I was there I started to realize
that that there is almost a hundred
years of science that clearly describes
the phenomenon that I was experiencing
and that hundred years of science is
actually one of the most powerful
solutions that that we've ever found for
treating this thing called diabetes in
all forms and you know can really be
applied to large numbers of people with
phenomenal results that being the case
then why is this not the conventional
dogma today in terms of treating
diabetes I mean this is a big question
right this is why you do what you do and
why you write your book absolutely yeah
I mean I think I wish we had the the
exactly Yuval guesses I think part of
the problem here is that doctors are not
trained to they're not trained in
nutrition first of all so they go
through medical school you know they go
through four years of medical school
plus a residency plus a fellowship
sometimes I can be almost a decade worth
of schooling and you ask your average
doctor hey how much nutrition do you
learn and they're like I don't know I
learned one class one day maybe six
hours right and their studies that
actually show that your average doctor
learns nutrition for a maximum of twenty
to twenty-five hours while they're in
med school so they're just not given the
training to talk about food and it's not
their fault because doctors are
phenomenal human beings
and they go into it with altruistic
tendencies but they're just not given
the right tool set so they leave Medical
School they go into their practice and
then when they when somebody with
diabetes or high cholesterol or
hypertension presents to them their
solution is like well I have this pill
that I you know can prescribe for you
because that's the system that I know
how to do right and so that's that's a
huge problem and then it sort of makes
it so that people living with diabetes
don't really have dietary options when
they go talk to a dietician who's been
trained in a much more traditional
setting their answer is low carbohydrate
so you're getting sorry go ahead yeah
that's part of the confusion around
diabetes it's one of the few chronic
conditions you can monitor on a meal by
meal basis you can look at your your own
cousin Peter back all day long writing
data and and like you said we're gonna
get into the weeds you know the cause
and what's going on here but yes it's
true if you do a low carbohydrate diet
you will see better numbers you'll see
flatlined blood glucose blood glucose on
your CGM so there is particular
confusion in diabetes that is very
nuanced and that is part of the reason I
think this approach has not caught on
yet because people don't understand the
confusion of the headlines and the
studies that are being cited just a lot
of misinformation so Cyrus when you're
getting your PhD and you're you're
digging deep into this stuff and you're
uncovering these studies that date back
decades and decades was this and and
when you would kind of present this to
your colleagues or you know whoever you
were working with at the time were they
on board with what you were finding and
kind of the path that you were blazing
or are they were they more on the
conventional path of like hey this isn't
really the way we do this no no they
they were very supportive actually
because you know whether it was talking
to other graduate students or whether it
was talking to my advisor or even some
of the other professors you know I would
be explaining the results of the
research so I was like you know my story
was one thing okay fine it's an
anecdotal experience it makes sense but
then when you translate that and you
start to get the same results in
laboratory animals because that's the
what you're supposed to be doing in
graduate school you know we are running
a whole collection of experiments to
induce insulin resistance in mice using
dietary methods and then reverse that
using either intermittent fasting or
diet or exercise so we were and the way
that you induce a diabetic response in
an animal is to is to put them on a
pretty high fat diet so that was another
epiphany for me right I'm sitting here
with you know tasked with the with the
objective of trying to make animals
insulin resistance so that we can use
them as a testing ground and when I
started looking in the literature I was
like how do I make an animal insulin
resistant okay I probably got to give
him a high fructose diet or high sucrose
diet and so I was looking in the
literature with that preconceived notion
and then it would I would read you know
we induced insulin resistance in
laboratory animals by feeding them a
diet containing 70% saturated fat for
eight weeks we induced insulin
resistance we induced type 2 diabetes in
laboratory animals you know by feeding
him a high-fat diet high fat diet
high-fat diet and I was like this is
unreal you feed animals a high-fat diet
and they develop diabetes why is it that
when when in the in the public when you
say the word diabetes the first
Association for the people makers is
sugar right yeah I had Neal Barnard on
the podcast I just put an episode up
with him last night but I had did a
previous episode with him where we
talked a lot about this and people went
crazy they're like that can't be true
because he was talking about the real
cause of this condition is people eat
too much fat 100% and that it's just
yeah that flies in the face of
everything that you thought that you
knew the disconnect between the research
and what the public believes and
understands is mind body its massive hmm
absolutely mind-boggling all right so
you have this epiphany so had this
Epiphany and then you know I start to
realize okay wait a minute the high-fat
diet that leads to insulin resistance
insulin resistance being the underlying
cause of pre diabetes pre-diabetes being
the underlying cause of type 2 diabetes
right the the stepwise progression is
person develops insulin resistance they
then progress to pre-diabetes and then
progress to type 2 diabetes that affects
90% of the diabetes population right
type ones like Robbie and I are like
eight to ten percent of the population
so that story I was like wait a minute
okay so
so does this mean that it could be that
people who are eating high fat diets in
the real world are actually developing a
state of insulin resistance that can
then progress the type 2 diabetes
themselves and the answer is absolutely
because these studies have also been
done in humans and the way to induced
insulin resistance in a human being
which we'll get into a thousand times
more detail is by feeding them a
high-fat diet right in terms of the
statistics obviously there's been an
explosion in the incidence of type 2 is
it similar with type 1 or is that
remained kind of a stable data point
that's it that's a phenomenal question
actually it's growing it's growing
yeah over the past 10 years there's been
a 23 percent increase in type 1 diabetes
and it's the first time in human history
that we've ever seen that and so
scientists are really struggling their
shoulders and throwing up their hands
and they're saying we don't know why
because type 1 diabetes has historically
only affected the same proportion of the
population so as the population grows
the proportion of the population stays
flat but now we're actually seeing an
increase in the in the proportion of the
population that's diagnosed with
autoimmune conditions in general type 1
diabetes for sure and you know who knows
why that's happening so type 1 is
essentially they're still trying to
figure out what what the kind of initial
cause of this is but essentially your
pancreas just stops functioning properly
and it's not secreting insulin yeah so
so for clarity your pancreas basically
has many many many functions so there's
what's called an exocrine function and
an endocrine function so the exocrine
function is is what 99% plus of your
pancreas is requires is occupied doing
and that exocrine function is to make
digestive hormones and so our digestive
enzymes such that when you eat food you
can digest that food these are like
amylases these are these are hide races
these are proteases these are lipases
right the other 1% of your of your
pancreas as is endocrine endocrine
meaning it's these cells secrete
hormones into your blood and then those
travel to various tissues to elicit
their biological effect so the beta
cells are part of these things called
islets clusters and the beta cells are
responsible
for making insulin and so those guys
secrete insulin into your blood and when
you develop type 1 diabetes the
autoimmune reaction is effectively your
own immune system that has been sort of
tricked or hijacked into believing and
and and targeting beta cells for
destruction so your own immune system is
manufacturing antibodies that basically
go and they they target proteins on the
cell surface of beta cells and they end
up disabling those beta cells so you end
up losing insulin production and as a
result of that 99 plus percent of your
pancreas is functioning just fine
it's that 1% that's not functioning and
all of a sudden that's non-recoverable
right got it okay before we get too far
into this body here your your version of
this so when I was 12 years old I had
the same symptoms cyrus head i was
thirsty all the time going to the
bathroom all the time
what's with the thirst thing is that bad
yeah so when your glucose level goes
really high then the concentration of
glucose inside here inside of your blood
increases your brain basically says oh
wait a minute let's drink more water so
that we can flush that glucose out so
it's a it's a way that you will take on
more fluid to decrease the
concentrations of glucose and then
eventually pee it out so it's a way of
just basically getting rid of the house
all right so I was quite familiar with
these symptoms because my older brother
was diagnosed with type 1 diabetes nine
years prior so I said to my mom I think
I have type 1 diabetes she said no no
don't be silly you don't have type 1
diabetes so she leaves town for a
weekend to go check out some places with
my dad in Florida because we were gonna
move to Florida we're living in st.
Cloud Minnesota mm-hmm so my mom calls a
check in and she says how are things
going I said mom I couldn't sleep last
night I was cramping she said okay go
upstairs test your blood glucose and
let's see what's going on so I test
myself on my brother's meter I'm over
400 so four times higher than I'm
supposed to be and my brother says write
that in there yep you have type 1
diabetes pack your bag you're gonna be
in the hospital for a few nights so we
go to the regular doctor they make the
diagnosis
I see my brother cry for the first time
he's like I'm just so sorry you have to
deal with this
and my parents fly back the next night
and my dad just said in the hospital
it's an inconvenience don't worry about
it you're still going to get to do
whenever you want in life and that was
sort of the way I was brought up I had
standard medical care I went to the Mayo
Clinic had an endocrinologist a
psychologist a dietician and looking
back it's really a missed opportunity I
think to really turn somebody on to a
better state of health whereas at that
point all they were saying is just eat
normal follow the standard American diet
just make sure you get every single food
group we want you to feel normal you're
a teenager
don't let this you know make you feel
weird that was the focus and you're at
the Mayo Clinic yeah exactly we think
you know the best care they could do a
little better but that's what happened
so life a type one begins I was a
competitive tennis player I have type A
personality I took pretty good care of
it you know I was on top of it I'd count
my carbohydrates i dosed my insulin
properly I'd fill out the logbook very
diligently to figure out what to do sort
of that guidance that you had suggested
that hey that probably would give right
so the Mayo Clinic did give that
guidance and I had you know pretty good
control but I had lots of other just
unfortunate symptoms like chronic
allergies of take a xanax and claritin-d
and still get sick all the time
I had plantar fasciitis which was very
frustrating as a tennis player I wore
these big blue boots at night to try and
do passive stretching I had warts on my
feet and in high school I developed
cystic acne it's really frustrating I
did all the treatments the creams the
pills the laser treatments
microdermabrasion eventually they put me
on accutane it's like the most serious
drug you can possibly take when you have
acne so your parents have to sign a
waiver because some people committed
suicide on that drug so I had these
frustrating symptoms but I was starting
to get into learning about how can I
take better care of myself just through
some of my dad selling supplements and
just it kind of resonated with me I just
kept on learning a little more a little
more hey trying to avoid the msg trying
to avoid the additives it just it kind
of made sense what was your dad slinging
he was his herb or the life
any different ones USANA eventually a
lot of different network marketing okay
so in high school I'm living in Florida
at this point and I stumbled across a
book called natural cures they don't
want you to know about okay this is by
Kevin Trudeau we are not recommending
this book this guy got put in jail for
fraud do you remember seeing those
commercials I don't know it's like a
purple board you guys drink smiling face
on the front it was crazy was it what
was his pitch so this book planted a
seed in my mind that would be possible
to reverse type one diabetes and that
changed the course of my life and I said
okay I'm gonna do anything and
everything to get my beta cells to work
again that was the - which is protocol
to do that yeah see it was just what it
was like one sentence was one sentence
in the book that planted the seed okay
wait it wasn't a particular protocol
right tell you how there was there was
all kinds of crazy things like colonics
and supplements the idea that that could
be possible yes that's exactly open the
door yes absolutely and my mindset was
hey people told Roger Bannister you
can't run a four-minute mile the
smartest people in the world said that's
not possible and then he did it and now
other people can run four-minute miles
so somebody's got to do it first so like
I will do anything and everything so
this leads me to try the Western a price
foundation which is a diet where you're
eating lots of grass-fed beef you're
having raw milk I would go to the local
farmers market and buy milk for a cat
because you couldn't sell raw milk to a
human so I was willing to do anything it
was crazy stuff and learning the
information like each step along the
path like it made sense okay that's
interesting that's interesting I'll try
this I'll try that grass-fed beef yeah
probably better than the beef from the
factory farms and stuff like that so I
did the Weston a price foundation diet I
didn't see any big difference in my
diabetes health so I continue to learn
eventually I come across a plant-based
ketogenic diet so this guy Gabriel
Cousins had a movie called raw for 30
days mhm and this is a diet where you
eat lots of greens lots of vegetables
but you're getting your calories from
nuts and seeds and oil so I started
trying that and of course now I'm
removing carbohydrates from my diet my
total insulin use is
coming down now I'm saying wow this is
working that's my goal I want to take
less and less insulin but in hindsight
that only makes sense if you know the
beta cells in your pancreas are
simultaneously
starting to make their own insulin but
that clearly wasn't the case in
hindsight so I'm following that diet and
I'm at the University of Florida this
time I'm a freshman and I'm on campus
and i black out several times it's just
really scary that moment like you just
kind of need to pause and like wait a
minute what's going on he'd like regroup
get home rest hypoglycemic I mean I
don't know exactly I mean yeah I
probably was a little bit but I think I
was just low-energy uh-huh
so I go back to my naturopath I'm like
what's going on here like what can we do
and she's like ok you know what maybe
you should do some chelation therapy
maybe that'll help you get rid of some
heavy metals and stuff like that I'm
like ok you know what I'll Drive from
Gainesville I'll go all the way to Tampa
and I'll try this therapy I'll do any
well daddy I'll do anything
I mean I also I flew to San Jose
California met with a Chinese medicine
man he may be this herbal tea
I have drinking that and call it smelled
so bad that I would brew it outside on
the sidewalk it was like a portable I'm
not a stranger to that good yeah I mean
they're done the guy had worked magic
for my father and some injuries he had
like put some like peanut butter stuff
on his arm and like it's crazy but I
didn't really see again any specific
results with my diabetes health so I'm
considering all my options trying all
this stuff but before I commit to the
chelation therapy I here Doug Graham on
a podcast and this is in September of
2006 and he's talking about you know
this fruit based diet also being able to
help you get rid of heavy metals and
cleanse your body like this is a healthy
thing to do like you know what I'm
missing fruit I would love beets and
fruit again I don't want to do this
expensive chelation therapy let me try
this so I start dabbling a little bit
the book finally comes out in December
of 2006 I read it straight through and
Cyrus is one of the testimonials in the
back I'm like wow this is interesting
the 80/10/10 yes he's all the
testimonials in there so I start
googling a little more about Cyrus I
find some pictures of him online
Latanya me all right this is like
looking Fanta my god this is cool this
is encouraging I'm gonna try this so I
started working with Doug Graham ie
every single day for 90 days straight he
emails me back every day for 90 days
straight and I learn how to do this
fruit based living and this is again
around Christmas time I remember going
down to eat Christmas dinner I have a
pyramid of bananas they don't like five
on the bottom and for them three my
family just looking and laughing like
this is gonna be another face it seen me
go through so many things and now we're
13 years later yes not a phase I mean if
you if you follow Robbie on Instagram
I'm like wow like that is so like this
this is like first of all like the the
amount of attention and like diligence
that you put into like preparing all of
this you create like these sort of
performance art like it's just it's like
all raw for it it's fun yeah and it
looks like a lot of food but I always
tell people it's a lot of water it's a
lot of fiber it's a little deceptive
yeah yeah yeah yeah so I start doing
this diet and just like sighs you would
expect you need to use way more insulin
your blog because should be way more
difficult to control and that's not what
happened my insulin sensitivity improved
by over 600% so you can calculate that
by taking a 24 hour insulin sensitivity
ratio you take your total carbohydrate
consumption divide that by your total
insulin use and you get a ratio there so
when I was doing the plant-based
ketogenic diet it was 3 to 130 grams of
carbohydrate per day one unit of insulin
now it's well over 30 grams of
no no sorry ten units of any one sorry I
tell you some insulin let's get you to a
3:1 ratio that's what I was using 10
years of insulin sorry yeah so then now
I'm it's the ratio is 22 to 1 I'm eating
over 750 grams of carbohydrate per day
and injecting roughly 27 units so it's
over 22 to 1 that's over 600 percent
improvement in insulin sensitivity and
this just gets me really excited so I'm
in college I decided to start looking up
some research looking into this Niel
Barnard's informations out there dr.
MacDougall's information that leads me
to the original studies and just like
cyrus i find this information has been
out there for almost a hundred years
that if you eat more car
hydrat rich food and limit the fat
consumption you improve the function of
insulin insulin resistance is caused by
a high-fat diet so it was really
transformative all my symptoms went away
plantar fasciitis gone my skin starts to
clear up I'm not using any more
medications no more creams I don't take
any allergy medications I don't get sick
no more warts on my feet and I'm feeling
energetic again really excited about
life at this point and I'm like you know
I'm gonna the Y was really strong again
I'm doing all this stuff because I'm
trying to get my beta cells to work
again so like okay this is gonna help my
body rest and rejuvenate and heal the
cells maybe my stem cells can make some
new beta cells I wish it was that simple
it's a little more complicated but that
was the mindset so I was just really
stoked about life okay let's just keep
doing this let's keep doing this it's
keep optimizing the insulin sensitivity
eating really well giving you a
nutrient-dense diet and let's see if we
get the beta cells working again so that
was the mindset and you've essentially
just built on that ever since right I
mean are you eating any vegetables at
all at this point I eat lots of non
starchy vegetables and lots of greens
yeah true right big-time so it's not
entirely a fruitarian doctor it's not
it's not a Michael Arnstein yeah we're
not advocating a fraternity Arian no
pure diet and and have you felt like do
you do we're kind of skipping ahead here
a little bit but like are you
supplementing at all like are you
worried about your omega threes and your
DHA and d it and like all that other
kind of stuff so like how does that all
work as far as Omega 3s essential fatty
acids I do not supplement and we
actually covered this thoroughly in the
book there's a lot of confusion when it
comes to essential fatty acids so the
two essential fatty acids are LA on the
omega-6 side and ala on the omega-3 side
and getting enough ala is not that
difficult I mean you can get it just by
eating enough calories but if you want
an insurance policy some nuts and seeds
well if you have one tablespoon of you
know flaxseed or one tablespoon of chia
seeds ideally ground up you already meet
your requirements for oh I and yet in
that to your point if you have some nuts
and seeds that's gonna increase your and
I can take no question yeah but the
issue is the
conversion process so people are
consuming too many omega-6 fats which is
inhibiting the conversion the same
enzyme Delta 60 saturates starts the
conversion process on both sides so if
you're eating too much omega-6 fats it's
gonna prefer that pathway and it's gonna
focus on doing the conversion on that
side and it's not enough enzymes left
over to do the conversion on the ala set
to can take the omega-3s and make epa
and DHA right so in the book we talk
about an end of to study which is our
own personal results and you can get
this quantified through an Omega quant
test and you can see what is your
essential fatty acid status inside the
membranes of your cells and our numbers
are extraordinary I mean mine was over
8% Cyrus's over 7% and people who are
supplementing people who are eating
excess nuts and seeds they're roughly
around 4% and they're happy with that
mmm interesting
all right so both you guys have this
epiphany and it flies in face in the
face of all this conventional wisdom
that you got to go
low-carb you're eating this unbelievably
high carbohydrate diet how are you like
when you go to the doctor like what is
it what are they what are your doctor
saying if this at this point early on my
under chronologist have never even asked
they don't look in the details they say
you know why your a1c is great your
insulin use is fine you don't have any
complications just 10 minutes let me in
and out write my prescriptions and
that's it so they're not even really
diving into three different
endocrinologist over the past 13 years
of following a low-fat plant-based whole
food diet not a single one of them knows
exactly what I eat
they've never know they don't ask so I
don't need to tell him right what about
you Cyrus yeah the when you go to an
endocrinologist office the like currency
that they ask you for is your blood
glucose meter or your CGM so they take a
device from you they then download the
information from that device and they
look at numbers and they say okay your
timing range was this highs lows okay
your a1c is doing this okay great
here's my prescription for you change
your insulin dosing strategy don't
change something like that nowhere in
that conversation does food enter into
the picture I had the opportunity to
bring it up once with
one of my endocrinologist and the
response that I got was like oh that's
really interesting yeah I guess a
plant-based diet works for some people
and I was like okay fair enough you know
like I didn't want to get into it but I
was like all right I understand you know
but for the most part just like Robbie's
saying 90 plus percent of all people's
you know doctors again they're not
trained and diet that's just not part of
their tool set and therefore it doesn't
even come up right but again I think if
there was a problem they would take the
time to look into it there just hasn't
been a problem gotcha
all right so we talked about what type
one is maybe we can talk a little bit
more about what type two is let's let's
kind of define our terms distinguishing
type two from pre-diabetic from insulin
resistant and also type one point five
which I'd never heard about until I was
listening to you guys talk about it
mm-hmm researchers believe there's more
people living with type 1.5 diabetes
than type one what is that it's a slow
onset version of type one okay so so
let's start it let's it's kids can be
very confusing so let's just think of
like diabetes as being like a general
umbrella term for like what could happen
the thing that you get when your blood
glucose becomes variable right within
that umbrella you have many different
things many different flavors we'll call
them right so you have the type one
which is Robbie and me so it's an
autoimmune condition like we described
earlier and generally it's considered a
strong autoimmune condition which means
that you express at least one sometimes
multi of the time multiple antibodies to
the beta cells and as a result of that
it's a rapid destruction happens within
12 to 18 months and then you go to full
insulin dependence and that can affect
kids as low and you know it from the age
of from birth all the way up to the age
of about 30 there's another type of
autoimmune diabetes which affects adults
greater than the age of 30 who also get
an autoimmune reaction but it's a weaker
autoimmune reaction so rather than
having multiple antibodies to the beta
cells or to insulin they usually only
express one it's not a hard and fast
rule but generally only one so as a
result of that type 1.5 diabetes is
considered adult onset adult onset slow
progressing
type 1 diabetes mmm yep and again over
the age of 30 there's people who are now
in their 60s that are getting the that
are diagnosed with autoimmune diabetes
its type 1.5 mm okay the third type of
diabetes is called pre-diabetes think of
pre-diabetes is like baby type-2
diabetes so it's the thing that you get
on the way to type 2 and like we were
talking about earlier insulin resistance
is the underlying condition that first
sets in and then insulin resistance
progresses to pre-diabetes you know that
you have pre-diabetes because you go to
the doctor you get your a1c value
measured and or your fasting glucose and
or your fasting insulin and those
numbers usually are showing a slight
elevation so as a result of that you get
this diagnosis of pre-diabetes but
usually people are given the warning
like hey if you make some lifestyle
changes right now you can go back to
being non diabetic right
it's your choice if pre-diabetes
progresses and continues to get worse
and the amount of insulin resistance
that you're experiencing grows then it
turns into type 2 diabetes type 2
diabetes occurs when again you are you
are quite insulin resistant glucose
levels are quite high you know fasting
glucose postprandial or post meal blood
glucose is high and the amount of
insulin that your pancreas is secreting
okay in this progression goes from being
normal to high in the pre-diabetic State
so your pancreas is like trying to to
control your bug because like hang on I
can secrete more I can secrete more so
pre-diabetics usually have a high
insulin level and then by the time you
get to type 2 diabetes the ability of
those beta cells to continue to
manufacture insulin has been compromised
so now instead of having a high in some
production you go back to having a
compromised insulin production okay so
it's like you started out at normal you
went into overdrive and then boom now
you fell you didn't fall to zero right
usually but you felt like you know
suboptimal 50% 60% normal insulin
production that's one type two sets in
and at that point the question really
becomes is it possible to go from type 2
back to pre-diabetes back to
non-diabetic and if so how would you do
it
and the answer is absolutely it can
happen in more than 80 percent sometimes
even 90% of all cases the question is
what are the lifestyle choices that you
put into play to make that happen
right and that's a complex question
right because you know there's so many
different types of there's so many
different worlds saying I know the
answer I know the answer I know the
answer but the idea is and General Allen
generality speaking yes you can move
from type 2 back to non-diabetic and it
happens for the majority of people and I
want to get into that solution but
before we do that maybe we should talk a
little bit about cause I mean when I was
a kid it wasn't even type 1 and type 2
it was like adult onset diabetes and
juvenile that's right right right and I
didn't know anybody that had what we now
commonly refer to as type 2 but we're in
a situation at the moment where I think
the statistics are something I mean you
would know much better than me but we're
verging on like 30% of Americans being
of adult Americans being diabetic or
pre-diabetic right and the childhood
rates are insane as well I mean where
are we at the moment yeah okay so the
statistics say by 2030 that 1 in 3
people in the United States will be
living with some form of diabetes it's
insane ok let's do the math on that how
many people we already have one-third
with the Prieta B's it's 85 million
people just don't know it correct
correct
so so what the statistics are saying is
that by 2030 so it's a fast forward ten
years from now there's gonna be a
massive diabetes problem with one out of
every three people walking around saying
I have diabetes I have type 2 diabetes
mainly right but what Robbie is saying
which is absolutely right which is at
today in 2020 there are 30 million
people approximately in the United
States that have been diagnosed with
some form of diabetes so about 1 to 3
million of those have type 1 and then
the other 27 to 33 million have type 2
in addition to those people there are
now 85 million other people who are
living with pre-diabetes but don't even
know it mm-hmm right so the total number
is somewhere about a hundred ten million
people who are living with some form of
blood glucose instability blood glucose
variation problem and majority of them
don't even know it and those are the
people that over the course of the next
ten years are gonna likely progress the
type 2 diabetes causing a huge you know
and even larger epidemic than we're
facing now and the cause is standard
American diet and not enough exercise
and living stressful lives essentially
excess calories excess saturated fat in
the diet not enough exercise high stress
no questions mm-hmm and the solution
with the diet being the biggest problem
of all yeah yes exactly right yeah all
right well let's talk about the solution
so we already kind of we already kind of
you know waded into it a little bit here
but you guys are coaching people you've
got this book mastering diabetes and
it's essentially you've created this
protocol to say look we're n of two but
here's what the research says here's
what the science says mhm
here's how we can hold your hand and
walk you through this process and get
you from your type 2 diabetic state or
you're pre-diabetic state and walk it
back yeah at the end of two and also
three thousand-plus people who've been
through our coaching program and like
you said a lot of research there's over
800 plus citations in that book and the
research goes back it goes back all the
way to the 1920s showcasing that the
more carbohydrate food you eat the lower
your insulin resistance that goes so I
mean insulin was first discovered in
1921 and it was first used in humans in
1922 so the around the Sun that's when
the whole conversation starts to emerge
about okay insulin sensitivity so 1926
dr. Sansom publishes the paper in the
journal of the American Medical
Association called the use of high
carbohydrate diets in treating diabetes
and this is the first time he said I
used a radical experiment in 150
patients adding bread potatoes fruit and
low-fat milk all right that's what he
adds and he finds that his patients
don't need to use more insulin so prior
to the discovery of insulin they were
fed a very very low carbohydrate diet
very high in fat very high in protein
just to keep people alive so that's what
was going on
they were having like 400 calories a day
it was miserable nobody liked the food
they couldn't think clearly they had no
energy so doctor Sansom feeds them this
higher carbohydrate diet and all of a
sudden they return to physical activity
they returned to their normal mental
capacity the diet actually tastes good
this is just the beginning then in the
1930s dr. Rabinowitz in Canada starts
practicing a higher carbohydrate diet
with his patients publishes several
papers in 1935 he publishes a paper
which is a five-year randomized
controlled trial in a hundred people 50
people try the old low carbohydrate diet
50 people try the new higher
carbohydrate diet okay he sees a 1%
reduction in insulin use on the old diet
and a 57 percent reduction in insulin
use on the higher carbohydrate demo okay
I mean he actually actually brought a
few statements here to read he concludes
carbohydrates increase whereas fats
decrease the sensitivity of the
individual animal and man to insulin
this is 1935 just researchers clearly
stating fat consumption impairs insulin
sensitivity then at the same time you
have dr. Hemsworth in the United Kingdom
he's publishing very fancy studies in
people who do not have diabetes so he
wants to test in normal human subjects
what's going on with insulin use
depending on what type of diet I feed
them so he gets a bunch of healthy young
male medical students he feeds them
seven different diets for the minimum of
seven days all right the high fat diets
80% of calories come from fat low fat
diet is 16 percent of calories coming
from fat ok and he sees there's a
stepwise improvement in insulin
sensitivity as he decreases the fat in
the diet get seven different diets over
seventy for this very very thorough
experiment he concludes that study
saying the greater the amount of
carbohydrate in the diet the greater the
sensitivity of the organism to insulin
again this is 1935 people are saying
this and then you skip to like the work
of Walter Kempner 1958 remember his work
I mean referring to speeding people
white rice uh-huh fruit juice fruit and
white sugar this is a diet of less than
5% of calories come from fat a very
highly processed it was originally
designed to treat hypertension okay so
he publishes a paper he's like he got
great results he was reversing heart
disease kidney disease all kinds of
stuff he was even skeptical what's gonna
happen if I feed this diet to people
living with diabetes so he publishes a
paper on 100 consecutive patients no
cherry-picking and they're eating all
these processed foods their fasting
blood glucose drops their insulin levels
drop their cholesterol drops and their
weight drops eating processed high
carbohydrate rich foods and what's
amazing is that the foreheads that heat
with fed people mm-hmm fruit fruit juice
white rice white table sugar these are
literally four of the foods or food
groups I would say that modern diet is
tell you to avoid all of those I mean we
vilified fruit but you know the other
ones seem Allah even more like of course
you're not supposed to do that yeah does
anybody ever studied what would happen
if you put a diabetic on like just they
just drink coca-cola neat candy like
just like pure table sugar okay that
question like no fruit no fiber for him
1971 doctor Bruns L publishes a paper in
the New England Journal of Medicine he
feeds people a sugar water diet
literally dextrose and a little bit of
protein powder
85% of calories coming from carbohydrate
15% from protein 0% from fat because
it's a processed diet when you eat a
whole food diet you can eat 0% fat
there's fat and lettuce there's fat and
bananas there's fat and apples there's
fat and everything you eat you just need
enough whole food you're gonna get like
six seventy percent of calories come
from fat so he feeds people this highly
processed diet so he had him on a
controlled diet there were 22 subjects
13 of them had pre-diabetes the rest did
not have diabetes okay
puts him on a controlled diet for seven
to ten days and then he feeds in the
sugar water diet there fasting blood
glucose levels drop eight percent in the
non diabetics nine point six percent and
the people having the pre-diabetes but
more importantly he does a paired or
glucose tolerance test so this is where
subjects are given a glucose challenge
like 75 grams of carbohydrate and like a
liquid solution and they going to
measure the blood glucose levels at
every 30 minutes and insulin levels
every 30 minutes for the next two to
three hours and he finds that on this
sugar water diet the blood glucose
values went down and their insulin
levels went down so they're eating
liquid sugar water requiring less
insulin with low so New England has
everyone so how come you're not just
like eating candies all the time well I
mean but what the point is is because
it's this is just the biology of what's
happening but as far as long-term health
overall health you've got microbe of
course you want to have nutrient-dense
foods that also happen to be low in fat
right okay but there's still one there's
a couple more studies that I think are
worth noting but the 1979 yeah tell them
uh that's 1979 my boy James W Anderson
he conducts a study at the University of
Kentucky with Kylene ward they take 20
subjects who are all living with type 2
diabetes for a minimum of two years he
puts him on a controlled diet you know
the standard I I think was like 40% of
counters from fat or so and then they
put him on a weight maintaining high
carbohydrate diet so this is not weight
loss can be attributed to any success
here and in 16 days 50 percent of the
subjects require zero insulin so these
are individuals that have been using
insulin for two years high fasting blood
glucose levels they were straight-up
type 2 diabetics and then he just
switches him to a diet they had and he
forces them to eat enough food so they
don't lose a single pound and within 16
days call it two weeks they're off
insulin altogether and what were they
eating specifically it was a lot of
starch high carbohydrate start a doze
rice things like thread mmm stuff like
that Wow
percent of calories was nine percent of
calories come from fat on that diet as
we go into the biochemistry which I know
we're gonna have Cyrus talked about you
understand why the low fat component is
so important so let's talk about what
happens conversely on a low carb
fad diet which is kind of the reigning
protocol for people that have this
condition it is either ketogenic or very
low carbohydrate you can't talk about
diabetes not talking about the ketogenic
diet 100% no question about it okay so
let's suppose that you're eating a low
carbohydrate diet eat so what that means
is that you're gonna be eating a diet
that contains somewhere between call it
70 to 85 percent fat in your diet and
then the remainder is going to be fat
protein and carbohydrate so a low
carbohydrate diet has been sort of
talked about you know for 30 40 50 years
at this point at this point we are now
in the ketogenic diet and the ketogenic
diet is basically considered a very low
carbohydrate diet so that means is that
the total number of carbohydrates they
were at the suggests per day is 30 grams
per day maximum divided between
breakfast and lunch and dinner so you're
eating 30 grams of carbohydrate plus
more than 150 to 170 grams of fat per
day so again we're looking at like an
80% fat intake you know then the room
ate a small amount of carbohydrate and
the remainder in protein okay so in that
situation when you eat a low
carbohydrate diet you're effectively
eating foods that are high in fat medium
and protein and the fat molecules that
are that are coming inside of your mouth
are actually locked up as triglyceride
in the food that you're eating so
triglyceride literally means glycerol
backbone with three fatty acids attached
to it so you're eating you know a lot of
that triglyceride it comes down your
esophagus it gets into your small
intestine in your small intestine the
the glycerol backbone is removed from
those fatty acids those fatty acids then
go through the wall of your small
intestine they get into your lymph
system your lymph circulates it into
your blood and then from your blood they
circulate in these particles called
chylomicrons chylomicrons are are
particles that can basically deliver
these fatty acids to tissues so you eat
it they get inside of your blood now
these column microns are basically
trying to give fatty acids to tissues so
if 100% of those fatty acid molecules
ended up inside of your fat tissue or
your adipose tissue then diabetes
probably wouldn't exist today
the problem is that those fatty acid
molecules a lot of them do get into your
adipose tissue which is where they
belong
it's a perfectly designed storage
warehouse to absorb fatty acids from the
blood when they're available but in
addition to getting inside of the fat
tissue they also get inside of your
muscle they also get inside of your
liver and that's okay if the total
quantity of fat in your diet is
maintained at a low level like Robbie
was saying 10% 15% maybe as high as 20%
okay but when you're eating a ketogenic
diet again you're eating 7080 percent
fat in your diet and as a result of that
the amount of fat that gets partitioned
inside of your muscle and inside of your
liver starts to grow over the course of
time so today you start a little bit
tomorrow you store a little bit more the
next day you store a little bit more and
over the course of time now your muscle
and liver have become effectively fatty
acid storage depots in addition to your
adipose tissue so your muscle and liver
are designed to store small amounts of
fatty acids and inside of each cell they
have this thing called a lipid droplet
the lipid droplet is effectively where
the the fatty acids are lipid soluble
comp compounds congregate together so
this lipid droplet starts to grow over
the course of time within each liver
cell within each muscle cell and
effectively that cell gets into a high
energy state where what it's trying to
communicate is like wow I have too much
stuff inside of me this lipid droplet
has grown each one of these fatty acid
molecules is worth is nine calories per
gram
and it's it's a very energy dense
molecule and so the cell effectively
says okay wait a minute we need to go
into self defense mode here and we need
to prevent more stuff from coming inside
so if it were able to block more fatty
acids from coming inside it would do so
the problem is that fatty acids can
easily get inside of tissues they can
easily get inside of your fat I'm sorry
your your liver and your muscle because
them the mechanisms to get fat inside of
there are not very highly regulated so
because these tissues can't really block
too much more fat from coming inside
what they can do is they can they can
block the ability to communicate with
insulin because the insulin is a
molecule that's mainly designed to allow
glucose to enter
tissues in addition to that glucose can
also signal fatty acids and amino acids
to come into tissues albeit just a
little bit less powerfully an insulin
glucose yes sorry so the cells do is
they basically say all right listen what
if we were to just shut down this
insulin signaling pathway because if we
did that then when insulin comes
knocking at the door we can basically
block pretty much all of glucose from
coming in and we can also block a small
amount of fatty acids and a small amount
of amino acids from coming inside
so intracellularly this lipid droplet
starts to create a traffic jam and this
traffic jam you know basically goes into
the the inside surface of these insulin
receptor and starts to alter some of the
proteins that start the insulin
signaling cascade on the surface of that
cell on the inside of that okay yeah so
the insulin receptor is kind of like out
into the surfer and you know in the
extracellular environment interacting
with insulin but then as when you cross
the cellular membrane on the inside
there's a whole bunch of there's that
there's another motif in that protein
and if you alter the way that that
protein functions or alter any of its
downstream signaling molecules then you
can basically shut down or strongly
inhibit the action of everything
underneath it so it's basel ii just a
game of dominoes let's just like alter
the first couple so that nothing else
but beneath it functions properly
so this lipid droplet ends up causing a
problem and impairing insulin signaling
so as a result of that the next time
that you go and eat a banana or you have
a bowl of quinoa or some wild rice as an
example that's carbohydrate rich food
those carbohydrates enter your digestive
system those carbohydrate chains get
broken down into glucose glucose is now
in circulation inside of your blood
glucose has to be accompanied by insulin
in order to get inside of tissues so
insulin comes knocking at the door says
hey knock knock I got this glucose do
you want to take it up and the cells
respond by saying we can't take it up
right now sorry we got all this lipid
that we got to take care of first or
some of the cells can't even hear
insulin because they've shut down the
entire signaling pathway so as a result
of that insulin is knocking it's
knocking it's knocking it's knocking
saying there's no response
knocking no response so as a result of
that the glucose gets trapped inside of
your blood right so you have literally
one banana and then you go check your
blood glucose two hours later and you
look at the number and you're like huh
245 I only had one banana
I guess bananas are bad for me see every
time I try and eat fruit my blood goes
goes high every time I eat potatoes my
blood glucose goes high I guess those
foods are bad for me I should eat less
carbohydrate rich food so when that
glucose is trapped in your bloodstream
with the insulin and the cells are sort
of refusing to uptake it does that then
prompt additional insulin secretion so
the insulin then continues to build in
the bloodstream like what is the
downstream impact of that and how does
that relate to insulin resistance yeah
someone knows his biochemistry great so
yes in that situation what we just
described that is classic insulin
resistance right so like we talked about
earlier insulin resistance can progress
into pre-diabetes and then eventually to
type 2 so in that state if you've
developed this this level of insulin
resistance a small amount of insulin
resistance then the beta cells inside of
your pancreas are saying you know what
the insulin that we just manufactured
and secreted into the blood it didn't
really do much let's make more mm-hmm
so then they go into sort of
overproduction mode and instead of
making call it five units for a given
meal they're gonna make seven units and
that happens today maybe those extra two
units they go and they get the job done
and it brings your blood glucose down
mm-hmm then tomorrow the same thing
happens and then the next day same thing
happens and then months and years down
the road before you know it normally
your pancreas was secreting call it 25
to 30 units of insulin per day and now
that 25 to 30 has grown to 40 50 60
sometimes it can be four to five times
as much as you were secreting in the
non-diabetic state so this domino effect
this cascading series of events can all
be tracked back to excess lipid intake
which which
and you know causes your your liver and
muscle cells to over accumulate these
lipids shut this whole thing down
exactly right
Wow yeah so what you can think of it as
like excess accumulation of liver I'm
sorry excess accumulation of saturated
fatty acids in tissues that are not
designed to store large amounts of fatty
acids that then causes a traffic jam of
glucose inside of your blood right and
in turn eating a low-carb or a ketogenic
diet that's high in fat is basically a
masking technique because you're not
taking in any carbohydrates you're not
you're not
prompting your your pancreas to secrete
any insulin so you're under the illusion
that you're dealing in this solution but
actually you're you're just basically
exacerbating a situation that will
manifest the minute you put any
carbohydrates into your body whatsoever
so you're actually exacerbating insulin
resistance by doing that you're just not
seeing the impact of that until or
unless you eat some carbohydrates that's
accurate so you you you live in an
insulin resistance state by eating a
ketogenic diet and you're making it
worse and you're making it worse over
the over the course of time and you're
playing the carbohydrate avoidance game
which allows you to never challenge your
liver or muscle with the you know to
uptake glucose large amounts of it and
as a result of that you literally cannot
see that you are living with insulin
resistance and to be fair I don't want
us to get ridiculed on Twitter okay so
if you do a low carbohydrate diet and
you lose you get results you you get
results but you also can see some
studies showing improvements and instant
sensitivity if they lose weight so there
is a small improvement but it's not the
same magnitude of improvement that we're
talking about here but once you lose the
weight and your weight stabilizes and
you perpetuate like a low carb diet
you'll be able to kind of maintain that
state right and your blood work will
will be stable you're gonna hit a
plateau yes and no yeah so I mean it is
possible sure
let's say you lost 40 pounds on a
ketogenic diet because weight loss is an
inevitable consequence and it's one of
the main things that happens and it's
one of the main reasons why people adopt
a ketogenic diet so they lose weight and
as a result of losing weight total
cholesterol drops HDL cholesterol
sometimes goes up triglycerides drop a1c
goes down fasting insulin goes down
fasting glucose goes down blood pressure
goes down so all these markers these
biomarkers start to move in the right
direction and you're like huh I've done
this only for a year this is fantastic
now I'm at my normal weight that's great
those are short-term results and those
are phenomenal and I'm not gonna take
that away from anybody who's experienced
that that's that's great but what a lot
of people who come to us relate to us is
that they say hey look I've been doing
this ketogenic thing I've been doing
this low carbohydrate thing for a while
but I can tell that I'm just not
functioning I'm not firing on all
cylinders right and what that means is
that they've either developed or are in
the process of developing other chronic
conditions like hypertension okay once
they've plateaued now things can move in
the wrong direction sometimes they get
high LDL cholesterol mm-hmm okay
sometimes they become hypertensive
sometimes they end up developing really
complex digestive problems they get gas
bloating constipation and that's
frequent and it prevents them from being
able to eat frequently a lot of people
say oh you know I just I have this brain
fog like I just cannot think clearly and
I don't know what's happening a lot of
people can't exercise frequently and so
there's all these sort of like ancillary
conditions that begin to accumulate over
the course of time some of them are
diagnoseable conditions some of them are
non diagnoseable conditions and it
generally makes people over the course
of a year to two years to three years
depending on the individual a lot of
them are like hah I don't know if I can
continue or want to continue to do this
anymore it's very difficult to maintain
and the one thing that's happening that
you cannot argue or disagree on is that
they have eaten themselves into a state
of glucose intolerance they'll say oh oh
I don't care like I'm not gonna eat a
banana anyway just never gonna eat a
Cobra
so what they can say if they want to
that's fine but the fact is they've
eaten themselves into a state of glucose
intolerance and the only way to get out
of it is to lower their fat intake and
eat more carbohydrate rich food which
they will do when they say oh yeah if I
want to become more insulin sensitive in
a perform well on oral glucose-tolerance
test I just have to carbon apt okay yes
you have to start adopting features of
the master diabetes method to become
more insulin sensitive in fairness to
that that that individual that's that's
got to be a scary prospect like if
they've been told their whole life or
ever since they've been diagnosed that
they got to eat low carb and they've
been doing it and they've been they've
gotten to a place of stability with that
for you to then say actually you got to
switch gears and do the exact opposite I
would imagine that that provokes a
little bit of fear and most people for
sure there's no question yeah no doubt
yeah I mean I think you're bringing up a
really important topic here which is the
psychology of this is just as important
as the the you know biochemistry yes I
would say this the psychology is even
more important right about chemistry
like we can nerd out on biochemistry all
day long but at the end of the day you
know it there's a certain amount of like
emotional anxiety that creates in people
when all of a sudden used you say to
them you know a couple of things like
number one you can't eat potatoes as an
example you can't eat fruits and I think
what people do is they translate that
message into oh so you're saying what
I've been doing is wrong right and and
then it can create a sort of like
negative mindset right right and sadness
exactly and in reality we never want to
point a finger at someone to be like yo
you're doing something wrong you know
again even in this conversation of low
carbohydrate diets we're gonna be very
clear we're not pointing a finger at any
individual we're just sort of saying the
science could require could use some
refinement mm-hmm think the conversation
about the science could use some
refinement and to be clear we also have
a lot of respect for people who choose
to adopt a look however I doubt that all
the experts people who choose like say
you know what I'm gonna do something
different I'm not just gonna go to
McDonald's eat standard American diet we
have a lot more in common than we don't
have in common you know as far as
lifestyle change there's a lot to
celebrate yeah everyone's they're all
trying to do the right thing
a great buddy is putting a lot of effort
towards it right so all right you've and
you guys have gotten together and you've
taken 3,000 people like forward 3,000
all so walk me through like how you know
the experience of onboarding somebody
into this and like how long it takes
before you start to see results and what
that looks like specifically
okay so Cyrus and I initially you know
you were working in like a biochemistry
lab to working to really enjoy I was
loving life at Forks Over knives having
a lot of fun we're changing a lot of
lives but the one thing that I realized
is that if you were a person living with
diabetes and you wanted some guidance
some coaching some support a go-to place
to adopt a plant-based diet and you know
manage your diabetes or reverse type 2
diabetes and pre-diabetes there wasn't
one place to go do you know neal barnard
he wrote the foreword of this book with
good friends with him he had a great
book he didn't have like a website a
destination you know joel firm has
written some good books and some good
information out there but there wasn't
one place actually get coaching and
support and the nuanced details of
diabetes in general and especially type
1 type 1.5 insulin dependent type 2 how
to manage all that so so we joined
forces 2017 we create an online group
coaching program that but that's our
passion is really working directly with
people uh-huh and so you joined the
coaching program there's three different
tools that we have to help people really
transition understand what to do we have
an online course which teaches people
step-by-step what to do and we help
people transition slowly okay a lot of
people they if you jump in make too many
changes you bite off more than you can
chew it can become challenging so we're
teaching people just change breakfast
just start there one step at a time and
then people start doing that and they
work through the program all the way
down to lunch to dinner to cleaning out
your pantry to go into restaurants all
the details okay so that's really step
one of onboarding with the master and
diabetes coaching program then you have
an online community and this is where we
have coaches who have a lot of
experience with diabetes several of them
have reversed type 2 diabetes themselves
at
Sud was on your show in the past these
people are gonna help you answer
questions every step of the way we
literally promise you post a question
we're gonna have a team member answer it
within 24 hours in addition to a coach
helping you out you are also gonna get
support from the community from a bunch
of other people living with diabetes
going through the same thing you're
going through and that is priceless
especially when somebody's struggling
and those are actually the posts that
get the most interaction so I'm gonna
said hey man I fought the wagon I feel
really bad you have all these people hey
it's okay I've been there I've dealt
with that I had this challenging family
interaction I have a challenging
situation with my doctor they're telling
me I shouldn't do this I'm gonna get my
health worse they've all these really
scary moments to have a place to go to
and get that support from other people
has been really valuable so that's
another part of our program but we also
do live coaching calls so the every the
first and third Sunday of every month we
do a zoom call so you can actually
interact with the coach interact with
the community but it's this really
supportive comprehensive program that
has helped us get amazing results in a
lot of people and we are publishing
testimonials all the time getting a new
story almost every day on our slack
thread and just hearing it through
Instagram and Facebook and are you able
to scale this or are you maxed out on
the number of people that you can deal
with I mean when people listening you
know there's gonna be people listening
to this yeah or dealing with these very
conditions so so we we do actually have
a waitlist so that is true but the goal
of we initially did coaching was just
iris nine okay we're just helping people
that's it and we realized that we can't
clone ourselves so we have to get other
coaches involved and that has definitely
helped us to scale this and that is our
plan we can help a lot of people for
sure yeah that's cool and once somebody
begins this process I'm sure it varies
depending upon the extent of their
condition but how quickly do people
start to see results days yeah
absolutely days especially if you're
living with insulin dependent diabetes
type 1 type 1.5 and some dependent type
2 you're injecting insulin and you start
eating more carbohydrates food it is not
expected to see your insulin use change
within 24-48 hours that's literally how
quickly it can wear off depending on how
much of a change you make so we have
four-day retreats people come down we
ran some in LA we've done something
Costa Rica now in four days people are
adjusting their insulin use dramatically
and they're literally eating unlimited
amounts of carbohydrate rich foods you
come there there's there's butternut
squash there's mangos there's papaya
there's beans just in individual bowls a
buffet go and take what you want we have
lots of vegetables lots of greens and
there's no calorie restriction at all
we're actually encouraging them to eat
more because that's one of the biggest
mistakes when people adopt this dye is
they don't eat enough yeah I know one of
the things that you that you do and you
lay this out in the book is you divide
these foods into kind of three buckets
like the green light the yellow light
and the red light and for foods that are
in this green light category it's like
easy you want there's really just just
eat until you you literally can't eat
anymore
absolutely and because they're so full
of water and fiber it's difficult to eat
too much of them and in the green light
category we have specifically listed the
carbohydrate-rich foods first fruits
starchy vegetables intact whole grains
legumes and then intact whole grains so
have those four categories listed first
because we want you to emphasize them
and I know people they're scared they're
absolutely scared in the beginning and
part of the book I think is
understanding the science and what's
actually happening in that for people
living with pre-diabetes type 2 diabetes
the high blood glucose reading is a
symptom of insulin resistance don't get
too lost in worrying about higher
readings in the beginning and we go
through a lot of tips and nuances that
you can apply to really handle that
depending on how insulin resistant you
are so there are certain foods you can
add lots more starch non starchy
vegetables lots more greens you add
foods like that to any given meal you're
going to slow down the rate of glucose
absorption and that's gonna help you
avoid spikes so there's lots of tweaks
we can make small amount even walking
after a meal can make a big difference
just walking in general anytime a day is
a huge huge difference for people living
with all forms of diabetes
so the foods that find themselves in the
greenlight category are fruits starchy
vegetables gums legumes intact whole
grains and then non starchy vegetables
leafy greens herbs and spices and
mushrooms uh-huh
yellow light are things like nuts and
seeds avocados things that are higher
and yes so these are healthy plant foods
they're whole plant foods they're
nutrient-dense
but you're exactly right they're a
little bit higher in fat actually a lot
higher in fat and you can easily eat way
too much of them which is not gonna help
your insulin sensitivity and definitely
not gonna have weight loss as well which
a lot of people are looking for who are
living with insulin resistance now we
also have highly high processed foods in
that category so brown rice pasta
Ezekiel bread foods like that it's a
little bit more processed the original
intact food it was made from so rather
have you have brown rice than brown rice
pasta but still it's in the yellow light
category and can be part of your diet
right and red light the red light is
basically everything else basically
everything else you know you have animal
products in there in oils in there
because it's a highly processed food
you've taken virtually all the vitamins
all the minerals all the antioxidants
all the carbohydrate all the protein
you've stripped it out you have
basically nothing but fat left very very
calorie dense it's easy to eat too much
also a lot of oils are gonna mess up
your omega-6 to omega-3 ratio so it's
best to just limit or avoid them to the
best of your ability and then we also
have processed foods I mean the basics
but I think it's worth pointing out
there's a lot of vegan processed foods
coming out now now more than ever
they're not health foods yeah so if you
want to enjoy them for other reasons go
ahead but if you're trying to reverse
insulin resistance it's not gonna help
you right what about beans beans double
green light green light yeah I think
yeah do you ask a question because you
enjoy eating beans yourself I ridiculous
amount of beans yeah yeah and I was
about the second meal effect oh yeah
okay one second here in in-fighting
ultra you talked about the fact that
when you finally transition to a
plant-based diet and you actually gave
it a good shot that you had to go
through some personalization as well
Yeah right you were sort of manipulating
your diet
to determine what's gonna give you the
best performance the best recovery and
what's gonna make you feel best were you
also at that time did you also get
excited about the the prospect of eating
lots of carbohydrate rich food like what
was the emotional under London feeling I
mean yeah I would say yes I wasn't I
mean I don't I didn't approach it with
an engineer's mindset in the way that
you might and I wasn't avoiding
carbohydrates prior to that I was just
trying to find a way to eat that would
keep my energy levels super high like
all the time and then as as the training
began to ramp up I mean my my diet is
much higher in fat than what you guys
are recommending and and and even this
conversation having it with you guys
right now is and and other conversations
that I've had with lots of other people
interesting people in this podcast that
do things similar to you as me
rethinking that and reducing my fat
intake considerably based at you know in
in comparison to what I have been doing
but when I was training 25 30 hours a
week yeah like lots of akkad OHS and
some higher fat stuff that you know I
probably wouldn't do now
fair enough was that there's this thing
called the athletes paradox which i
think is actually phenomenal it's very
interesting which is that some research
actually shows that the lipid droplet
also grows inside of inside of muscle
tissue of athletes who are eating a
slightly higher fat intake but it's not
problematic because that lipid Depot is
basically it grows and shrinks and grows
and shrinks rapidly hmm so as a result
of doing endurance sports a result of
being a frequent athlete that becomes a
fuel depot rather than a pathological
you know it's so urgent about training
well let's talk about what what you mean
when you say reversal like reversal
remission like are you is it possible to
cure type-2 diabetes like what do you
actually mean okay great question I
think this is actually it can be kind of
controversial to even talk about this
because it means different things to
different people
so when we refer to reversing we we talk
about reversing insulin resistance
because that's the underlying cause of
pre-diabetes and type 2 diabetes and
it's the thing that makes your blood
glucose wonky and when it comes to
reversing type 2 diabetes as an example
what you want to do is drop your a1c
value or anyone sees basically like I
said 3-month an indicator that tells you
what your blood glucose stability has
been over the course of three months and
so the the standard is to get your blood
your a1c to less than a five point seven
percent okay so between five point seven
and six point four is considered
pre-diabetes and then six point five and
Beyond is considered type two so let's
say start out at a seven point O and
then you drop that from a seven to a six
from a six to a five point five boom
you're at a five point five technically
you're in the Green Zone you're in the
non-diabetic range cool let's stay there
in addition to that we also want to see
a low fasting blood glucose and a low
fasting insulin so a low fasting blood
glucose means less than a hundred
milligrams per deciliter and low fasting
insulin means less than five okay so if
you can achieve all three of those then
technically speaking you're in the safe
zone but what we want to see is that you
maintain that not only do just get it
today I want you to maintain that for a
year all right I want you to prove to me
that your lifestyle is dialed in enough
that you can maintain all of those
biomarkers for a year now those are
those two markers the fasting insulin
and fasting glucose are indicators of
what your fasting metabolism is doing
and that's important no question but
it's also important to make sure that
your glucose challenged metabolism is
also functioning well and the glucose
challenged metabolism effectively refers
to what happens after you eat a
carbohydrate rich meal right so if you
were to go eat a carbohydrate rich meal
I also want to make make sure that your
fat your post meal insulin is not high
and that your post meal blood glucose is
also not high right now in the world of
ketogenic diets what we're talking about
earlier a lot of the research focuses on
what's happening in the fasting state
because again you lose weight you drop
your fasting glucose you drop your
fasting insulin
drop her a1c everything looks good but
they're using that as a collection of
information to say good job you've
reversed type-2 diabetes but they're not
testing the glucose challenge State
mm-hmm and if you're not testing the
glucose challenge state then you're bit
missing an entire that's the real marker
of just how insulin resistant you are or
not
exactly so that's why what we like to
say is let's get the biomarkers set in
the in the fasting state and let's get
them set in the in the glucose challenge
state mm-hm and if you can do both of
those and you can maintain that over the
course of time give me a full year then
we can say that you've reversed type 2
diabetes altogether so I mean I don't
think the exact words matters it
reversal is a cure is it remission it's
what's happening in real people's lives
people who come to us with a high a1c
they're taking diabetes medications they
have fatty liver disease they have no
energy okay so we get them they don't
need medication anymore I mean I just
pulled up the story Tammy because she's
one of my favorite testimonials she
actually lives here in Los Angeles I got
to meet her at the farmers market when
she joined our program her a1c was seven
point two percent and she was using
metformin so that's a common diabetes
medications that's a high a one C
medicated now she follows our program
she gets eat all the carbohydrate rich
food she wants unlimited amounts she
reduces their a1c 25.3% unmedicated so
totally off the metaphor yeah so at that
point what I don't care what you want to
call that right averse it doesn't matter
she's she's non-diabetic she's removed
the cause of the problem and now she's
able to metabolize glucose but most
importantly she also had insulin data so
when she was living with type 2 diabetes
had the elevated a1c still using
metformin for fasting insulin was 17.4
this is very high now she starts eating
our diet doesn't need the medication
anymore as lost weight her fasting
insulin is 5.2 that's healthy that's
where it's supposed to dance crazy is
there ever a situation where somebody's
type 2 diabetes is sope regret like the
extreme examples of this being unchecked
for a very long time somebody's very
overweight like that person who's going
to get you know their
foot amputated or whatever where it's
just even even to like put them on this
program like it's too late or or do you
always see improvement it's never too
late so but this is a really important
topic we're actually quite passionate
about it and we wrote about this in the
book there is a situation where you can
become an insulin dependent type 2
that's actually real so if you have gone
through that situation where Cyrus was
talking about all the insulin being
produced and knocking on the door it's
possible that your beta cells have
become exhausted and you literally
aren't able to produce enough insulin to
manage your blood glucose level without
exhaustion as insulin so you're more
like a type one without the autoimmunity
right without the antibodies and that's
okay so we talked about c-peptide
testing you can go and get a test done
you can figure out and establish how
well are your beta cells working how
much insulin are you producing and then
we can gauge your goals yeah it's cool
and so yeah you you at that point okay
for of course they're more like Cyrus
and I they're more like a type one
there's still no reason not to gain some
more energy to reduce your risk of heart
disease which is the number one killer
of people living with all forms of
diabetes introduce your risk of fatty
liver disease chronic kidney disease
high cholesterol high blood pressure
erectile dysfunction depression you name
it you want to maximize your insulin
sensitivity where do you guys come down
on intermittent fasting oh ho huge fans
huge fans um I when I was in graduate
school I got to study intermittent
fasting and and many different
permutations of it and how it affected
you know animals in the insulin
resistance state and the results that we
were getting were just phenomenal so we
were learning about different techniques
that other research labs had used to to
improve the health of you know either
animals or humans and there's there's a
whole laundry list of different
intermittent fasting strategies and
permutations so we were testing out what
happens in at 25% calorie restricted
state which basically means you eat 25%
less food than you normally would and
you hold that constant every single day
then there's what's called an alternate
day fasting strategy where you eat today
that nothing
the need today than nothing tomorrow
then there's 25% alternate day fasting
eat today and then you only have 25% of
your normal food and on and off on and
off so in the bassinet abuse program we
we implement we basically teach people
how to implement one of two different
strategies the sort of beginner strategy
and where we recommend starting would be
a once per week 24-hour intermittent
fast mm-hmm and when you do a once per
week 24-hour in a min fast I think it
solves many problems number one is it's
an opportunity to recognize the
difference between true physiological
hunger and mental hunger or emotional
hunger all right I'm sure you've
probably felt that before you know most
people think that they're truly hungry
but in reality they're not necessarily
it's just you know it's time it's
programmed oh it's six o'clock p.m. it's
dinnertime all right I smell that pizza
so therefore I want food so this is an
opportunity to sort of really recognize
what is true physiological hunger and
what is now that's a psychological
experiment that is an absolute
psychological experiment no question and
then in addition to that people who are
living with insulin dependent type I you
know you type one diabetes or insulin
dependent type 2 diabetes are able to
use it as an opportunity to check
whether their basal or their background
insulin is set properly
are they injecting the right amount and
if so then their blood glucose is stable
if they're injecting either too much or
too little their blood glucose will do
some funny thing because in in that
period without food you get some kind of
baseline reading that you can set your
parameters on exactly so if you're using
an insulin pump as an example the
insulin pump is literally just drip
irrigating insulin into your bloodstream
or into the subcutaneous tissue that
gets into your blood Rich's healthy
pancreas he's doing that right now this
is a key right yeah so that's the thing
like my friend Robin our jean has a
thing on her tricep you know like a
little box thing there yeah that's what
that's doing yes she has an omni pod
right and she also you guys don't have
that so we do not personally use pumps
but she also has a continuous glucose
monitor a CGM she wears a Dexcom but
yeah don't blank stare
the glucose monitor it's new technology
uh-huh and what it's doing is it is
actually measuring subcutaneous fluid
right they have a she's got like a
little doodad like that's not her phone
that she's like looking at all the time
looks like a pager yeah yeah now she's
probably doing it on her phone because
they didn't hear with you know but yeah
so anyways it's giving you 24/7 data on
your blood glucose values every five
minutes you get a new number from these
continuous glucose monitors and it's
fascinating data and now for people
living with type 1 and type 1.5 this
concept of time in range has become a
very big deal so we can now see what
percent of any given period of time are
you spending and in any range so the
type one community has established
between 70 and 180 milligrams per
deciliter that is in range you want to
try and be there as much as possible a
minimum of 70% that's the goal and then
to be low that would be 69 or lower you
want to be there four percent okay no
more than four percent max and then less
than 55 no more than one percent so
below one percent in a very urgent low
and then you want to minimize the high
so above 180 you want to try and be
there as little as possible so they have
done some studies and New England
Journal of Medicine some high quality
journals have look into this what's
actually happening with people with type
1 diabetes right now how good is their
time in range and people who are using a
pump they see a little bit of an
improvement they're getting you know
maybe somewhere around like 65 percent
of their time spent in range but then
this new technology called a closed-loop
system also known as an artificial
pancreas is getting people on average
closer to the 70 percent threshold that
we're looking for here seventy-five
percent okay now this is where the pump
and the CGM are talking to each other so
the CGM says oh hey you're going up
you're 115 going up so that talks for
the pump of the pump says okay you know
what you need one unit of insulin let's
bring you back down and where it's
really helpful is when people are
sleeping so it makes these small micro
adjustments overnight helps them keep a
steady blood glucose profile but even
then I want to make a point here they're
still getting somewhere around my
seventy seventy five percent on average
I have become personally very passionate
about this topic I'm like hey if I'm
gonna be an educator in this field like
I should have some good numbers here so
here look into this let me start looking
at this data and I've started to pay
close attention to it and over the past
90 days my time and range is 91% Wow
which is again people with the closed
loop system are they're getting the some
people are getting close to that I mean
it's not that often
so without a system without antiquated
technology I'm at 91% my low is 3% less
than well less than 55 is less than 1%
and then the high is 6% so in addition
to the time and range data we now also
can have an average blood glucose value
throughout the entire day and it's not
based on just finger pricks it's 20 you
can't hide from this data and so we can
see okay what's your average over
24-hour period and that number you can
also figure out okay what's the standard
deviation what's the fluctuation from
your average and you want that to be you
want your standard deviation to be less
than one-third less than one-third okay
of the value yeah and mine is about 1/4
so you're basically flattening that sine
curve exactly and so what I'm trying to
demonstrate here and what we're doing
here with the master babies method it's
like I'm not special I'm just telling I
promise you if you apply these
principles it's just matter what form of
diabetes you're living with you can get
your blood glucose under excellent
control you are not gonna see these
peaks and valleys but you would expect
with carbohydrate rich food and so I
have the data to show that hey I'm doing
that myself
and I'm not even having the best
technology doing it yeah but Robbie
bacon today you know people like their
high fatty foods man yeah you know and
you know we teach that in our program in
the book we say we're not the food
police it's your choice
we're just here to teach you the
consequences and you can get whatever
result you want we're just giving you
the information and the support if you
want it Robin is one of the most active
energetic people I've ever met and you
guys seem like you have a lot of energy
like are there things that you can't do
it like as as people who are athletic
like you find that you can
go out there and be all you can be and
do all the stuff that you want to do
without running into problems okay so
how does that work with someone who has
a progressed state of type - all right
so the number of stories that are
popping into my head right now is just
like Dean Dean Dean Dean Dean okay
when I first transitioned to a low-fat
plant-based whole food diet one of the
first things I felt not only was my
glucose more controllable my insulin use
is down but I literally felt like I took
a like a wall charger and stuck it in a
wall and I just got like electrified so
I felt the energy boost immediately and
as a result of that I went out and
bought a bike and I started cycling all
over the place and a new guy wrote
brother yeah you know it is I think I
wrote something like 6,000 miles in the
first year because I was literally just
excited and I told people at that time I
was they would see though why are you up
at six o'clock in the morning and I'm
like I feel like a puppy I like I wake
up and I just have all this energy and I
don't know what to do with it right so
I've experienced that Robyn is a perfect
example we taught her this method right
and we sort of were like hey you know
how do you feel about this and so she's
like great let's do it when I was
talking with her not too long ago she
said hey one of the things that uh one
of the best benefits of this is I
thought I had a lot of energy beforehand
but now my boyfriend makes fun of me all
the time because he says that I don't
stop yeah right and I was doesn't she
literally does not yeah and her her her
now-husband i mean he's you know he's
one of the most fit dudes ever now yeah
so take the Robin that you know and then
add another 20 30 40 okay then in
addition to that one of the one of the
best stories that we've you know been
able to influence is there as a woman
named Marilyn who came into our program
and she was literally house ridden couch
ridden she'd been living with type 1
diabetes for I want to say 60 plus years
and she had so little energy that on a
given daily basis she could not even
leave her house she was hardcore
ketogenic hardcore so she was very
ketogenic leading up to that she her
glucose was under exceptional control
yeah while eating a ketogenic diet but
she was like I think so I'm missing
something
so she comes over to starts learning
from us
her glucose is under great control
following this approach as well and over
the course of I want to say it took her
in her particular situation about one
and a half to two years to get to a
point where she started to really feel
it right so there was there was a lot of
work that had to be done underneath but
she eventually became a little bit more
active inside of her house and then she
eventually started going outside of her
house to go get things and then she now
gets on a bicycle and goes and rides her
bike for ten ten miles a day yeah and
then she's like you have fundamentally
changed my body and my life and I'm like
I didn't do anything
Marilyn you did all the work here it's
the classic example she had a once he's
in the force consistently and you think
oh this is great what was the long-term
consequence she became house ridden so
yeah exactly
is there what's the deal I mean
basically you guys are eating a raw diet
right it's it's it's predominantly raw
like where where do you come down on
like cooked foods and I mean you like
beans so you got a Coco's right so we're
definitely we're not teaching a raw food
diet that's not definitely not like I
focus it on you stayed clear like you're
not labeling this you know you you guys
avoid words like vegan and raw and all
that kind of stuff I get that you know
but I just want to kind of drill down
for sure so we get the nuances of both
of our personal stories yes it is true I
still still do follow a raw food diet I
eat lots of non starchy vegetables lots
of greens I could do this for a long
time it's open over 13 years now and I
eat prime my calories comfy tough fallen
out see they're still working just fine
[Laughter]
and Cyrus and he's added some foods yeah
so I I was raw for I don't know 14 years
or so and I just decided that I wanted
to start eating potatoes so I started
eating potatoes quinoa garbanzo beans
black beans steamed vegetables and those
are all in my diet right now and how did
that doesn't impact your blood work like
what was that any changes that you saw
when you did that or why did you decide
to start doing that yeah I decide to
start doing that because when I would go
to like you know go to rest
and go out to dinner with people I would
always kind of like be eyeing the food
and I was sort of like oh I don't want
to eat some of that right and then I
said you know what what if I were to
just try incorporating it so the first
time I tried incorporating cooked foods
it it did not do good things to my blood
glucose my blood glucose went high and
as a result of that I had to use more
insulin and I was like man this is
frustrating but what I've learned in
this process is that there are certain
cooked foods which are very non
problematic you know I can eat quinoa as
much as I want I can eat garbanzo beans
as much as I want steamed vegetable as
much as I want and it's not gonna budge
my blood glucose but there are certain
types of beans for some reason that I
cannot explain that make my look like
let's go crazy and just to be clear this
is these are nuances of living with
insulin dependent diabetes type 2 there
is no restriction on any of these
healthy cooked foods that we're talking
about in the book now I'm probably have
like 30 recipes in here I'm pretty sure
like 26 of them that I cooked couple raw
food ones in there so let's let's blow a
few minds and you guys can walk me
through what you eat let's like get down
to brass tacks yeah on what this
actually is so I mean we're just go to
either of your Instagram for sure your
Instagram has the word mango in the in
it people call me the mango man yeah I
mean personally I will eat for breakfast
I mean right now persimmons are in
season I go but I should say you you
gifted me with this beautiful fruit bag
that's some high-quality fruit there
thank you local grown Valencia pride
mangoes very special
Hachiya persimmons which are there like
up you gotta eat them when they're like
a balloon he won't even give me some of
those foods yeah that's a great fruit so
anyways you know every meal is
essentially fruits and greens like
pretty and I eat four times a day I have
breakfast I have launch I have a pre
dinner and I have dinner so breakfast
it's gonna be whatever see whatever
fruits are in season but a particularly
calorie dense fruit so persimmons are
much more calorie dense than something
like melons so you know we and we list
all the foods in the book in order of
calorie density so people can use that
as a tool to make sure they're staying
satisfied
sticking to the program long term and
then lunches again gonna be another
fruit based meal again final blow some
people's minds i will commonly eat well
over 210 grams a total carbohydrate at a
lunch meal that's my biggest meal of the
day and if you're following a ketogenic
diet and you're staying 230 grams of
carbohydrate or less per day you're
eating 210 per week so I'm eating more
carbohydrate than a low cut person is
eating in one week but here's most use
the kicker rich there's published
research people with living with type 1
diabetes following a ketogenic diet will
use on average 30 units of insulin per
day 30 grams of carbohydrate 30 units of
total insolence a one to one ratio I am
eating over 700 grams of carbohydrate
per day and using 27 total units Wow
that's mind-blowing if people really let
that sink in and that's the conversation
of this whole book about maximizing
insulin sensitivity or reverse sizes in
the size of your your lunch meal is like
the size of your physical body
I used to think that I could eat in the
night Robin I was like wow no question
about it my preview is gonna have like
some blueberries some bell peppers some
mango some greens I love arugula I love
spinach I like specific varieties that
gift you some Bloomsdale spinach yeah
special stuff and then dinner is a very
high you know vegetable based meal you
know lots of greens again I'm lucky I
live in LA I get to have different
varieties of lettuce like I'm sort
lettuce you know green Oh blah yeah it's
fun green peas sugar snap peas stuff
like that and then of course there's
some fruit in my dinner so I have some
mangoes there some berries stuff like
that
Cyrus okay so because I live in Costa
Rica I get to eat lots of plantains lots
of papaya lots of mangos I just have
this vision of you sitting on the beach
just eating fruit wearing board shorts
just stuff for hours and ties to go do
it do a webinar
okay so for breakfast I will wake up and
I will eat maybe one plantain raw
plantain which people find weird but
it's very tasty so eat like one giant
raw plantain and then maybe like half of
a Mara doll papaya you know those like
big Mexican papaya okay then I'll go and
I'll do a workout I'll go to CrossFit
for an hour and then I'll come back and
my wife Kylie will put together some
type of like giant fruit bowl slash
smoothie Bowl for me so I'll eat that
and that usually contains maybe another
three plantains plus two mangos and some
berries and maybe you know another half
of a papaya okay so fruit heavy
breakfast fruit every second breakfast
lunch rolls around I still eat some more
fruit why cuz I really like it just like
Robbie okay this whole free thing just
like say this the people that I know I
know you don't characterize what you do
is a fruitarian diet but the people that
I know that that like are like
fruitarians quote unquote
okay I've never seen people more in love
with what they eat like they just want
to talk about it like yeah like
romanticize it I'm like what is what is
that about there's like I'm not gonna
like write poetry about it I wish I
explained cuz I seriously I have the
same issue and Cyrus actually makes fun
of me he cares away less about like this
particular variety yeah like the
rightness and I got all these farmers
markets I don't know what to say rich I
just love it it's like a Saturday Night
Live skit okay no but when it comes to
mangoes I am mildly obsessed with them
and so like this fascination with like
different types and different shapes and
different colors and whatnot I'm wailing
well into that when I was living in
Hawaii back in 2005 and 2006
I wanted to set the world record for
eating mangoes so I mapped out all of
the mango trees on the south a part of
Oahu and I would drive by them every
single day and I would go mango hunting
uh-huh and then I would had a bucket in
the back of my truck and I would just go
to people's houses and then I would pick
up the Fallen mangoes and I would just
eat those is this like a series
on YouTube right so during that time I
was eating 23 mangoes a day on average
over a three and a half month period and
I was eating a 17 1703 mango all right
and again I was trying to set the world
record applied to the guinness book
isn't world record did somebody hold
this sword well I tried to set the world
sorry I applied for the Guinness Book
and they basically said we don't do food
eating records it promotes too much
competitive ism you're gonna have to go
to this other organization to do it so I
said fine I hold the unofficial world
record or money again
so 1750 mangoes and three half months
but really what I wanted to do was set
the world record for a 24-hour period
alright and eat something like fifty
mangoes on 24-hour period or more point
you could still do that I could point
being so you know it's like fruit heavy
up until lunch and then when you know
middle of the afternoon and dinner rolls
around that's when I go into more on
vegetables so that's when I eat things
like chickpeas I'll have some steamed
vegetables I might have a giant salad I
might have some red beans I might add a
little bit of rice in as well so you
know I used to be 100% raw but now I'm
you know whatever
70 percent raw and your wife she eats
the same way she does she's a little bit
less fruit obsessed than than we are she
tends to eat a little bit more cooked
food but she's you know whole food
plant-based low-fat loving it one of the
things that I can imagine you know
somebody listening to this right now
might be thinking is like wow maybe I
need to take a look at this
but it's intimidating like because I
think for the social aspect of it like
oh I guess I can just never go to a
friend's house again or I can never go
to a restaurant like I I could see
people panicking over how how they could
actually make this function yeah well
again when you look at the list of foods
that can be eaten
you actually can eat this way very well
and enjoy it at just about any
restaurant you really can I mean I've
been 13 years now a lot of business
meetings a lot of restaurants a lot of
traveling you can make it work and I
I also want to remind people it's not
about being perfect you know you may be
a little intimidated maybe so I don't
want to give this up like small changes
make a big difference and I can tell you
like almost every success story we
publish like they'll say I'm not perfect
well get consistently regular posts in
our Facebook group of like I have been
like kind of struggling I haven't really
been doing it I just got back to my
doctor I couldn't believe how good my
a1c was I couldn't believe how much
weight I'm still losing my my blood
pressure went down like all these
amazing things are happening even if you
don't go all the way so I want people to
think like oh you have to be you know
perfect and eat this amazing clean diet
that we just described you don't have to
do that in general but even when it
comes to social situations like there
there's a lot of nuanced things you can
do either you can prepare a dish before
you go you can learn how to communicate
with them and if you're living with
diabetes and your use that as sort of
like a clear communication of why you're
doing this a lot of people will get
behind you
same thing with using you know
communicating with a waiter you know we
have strategies for that you can sort of
pull them aside and let them know hey I
have these specific goals and you can
add some humor in there make sort of
funny like Cyrus will tell the waiter
I'm trying to set the world record for
insulin sensitivity can you help me out
if you put a little oil in there you're
gonna crush my hopes and dreams so let
you know there's ways to make it fun and
I really think it comes down to your
desire your goals figuring out what your
Y is figure out what's important and if
you can communicate that to the people
you love they're gonna support you and
you can get through any situation mm-hmm
yeah I think that's good advice and I
think if you are dealing with diabetes
you have a perfect thing to hang your
hat on and say this is why I'm doing it
as opposed to like oh this is just the
freaky new thing that I stumbled across
exactly the new year and making sure
that you're focusing on hey this is me
this is what I'm doing for my health
you're not saying what you're doing is
wrong or the way you eat is bad if you
can really establish that level of
comfort and support hey I'm just I'm
just doing this for me like I'm just
trying I'm just testing it out are you
supposed to avoid those things that's
the conversation that well I would
sooo all right I got a land this plane
in a few minutes but the last thing I
want to talk to you about really out of
just my own personal curiosity is about
YouTube culture like you're you know
you're not like a vlogger but like I can
sit or you as as somebody who's kind of
part of that ecosystem sure have like
the vegan YouTube community at large and
it's been fascinating to me to kind of
observe at arm's length the evolution of
that whole dynamic your over the last
several years and for the most part I
think it's been an absolute show
and I'm just I'm interested in kind of
your relationship to that world and your
perspective on it I think it's involved
like it there's a lot of really cool
stuff that's happening there now exactly
and I think the content that you guys
are putting out like super high quality
but yeah I've sort of watched you know
it start out as this kind of cultish
thing and then became kind of a vlogger
thing and then it kind of devolved into
a lot of mudslinging gossip and very
unproductive yeah you know dysfunctional
behavior exactly we do not participate
in that and I think that everybody
should know the evolution of YouTube and
I think in general think this movement
on a lot of levels is the focus on
evidence-based information and there are
channels popping up that are putting
that at the center of what they're
communicating versus Lykes a vegan I
think is yes amazing absolutely yeah I
love that base news like there's some
really great channels that they're doing
really solid work exactly and so I think
we've graduated from that contest
gestation phase taking away the emphasis
on n of one examples and being oh I'm
gonna listen to this blogger because
that's what they said oh and then when
they said it didn't work for them then
I'll just listen to why they why didn't
work for them it's it's it's too small
of a sample size you can't make
decisions based on bloggers yeah you
really got to look at the evidence it
could be inspiring it could be
interesting but go and look at the
research what about all these people
making I mean we're kind of past this
now but there was that whole sort of
season of like why I'm no longer vegan
it was very unfortunate I mean it's
probably not gonna disappear
unfortunately but but again it's just
you got to remember to look at the
research and not get lost in the details
of individual stories and I think if you
look at some of the nuances of a lot of
those stories you realize that we don't
we don't know a fraction of what's
really going on in people's lives for
how long are people showing they're
looking amazing they're feeling amazing
they're doing this they're selling
programs or whatever and then behind the
scenes you know we find out no that's
not what was going on yeah so you just
have to take it all with a grain of salt
and I think there's also a huge growth
in evidence-based doctors and being able
to access that I think that the
Instagram culture sort of like taking
over you know and now instead of
vlogging its Instagram story yeah and
the amount of doctors who are
participating in that game and giving
really solid information is very
encouraging for the so who-who are the
go-to people in your guys's estimation
Danielle doctor will be dr. B will busca
wits gastroenterologist unbelievably
smart yeah dr. Danielle Bilardo dr.
Michele McMackin dr. Rob Oz felt Who am
I missing dr. Joel kaan yeah there's dr.
Michael Greger
all participating in the Instagram cause
it really has shifted to see doctors you
know these really well-respected people
making instagram stories it's kind of
funny like when I saw this happen you
know you're not we've been around a long
a long time this Instagram thing when I
was just you know the homepage was one
homepage for everybody okay everybody
saw the one high note remember it like
if you got your picture on that homepage
that was like that was the page at
everybody all over the world saw the
same thing absolutely and all it was was
pretty food photos yeah that was it and
now Instagram posts they're kind of like
replacing blog posts people are posting
really yeah solid educational content in
an Instagram post and also illustrating
it with great pictures you're sliding
through you're seeing the pictures
you're seeing the videos we're doing a
lot of that on our Instagram account so
it's been fun to see the evolution cool
all right you guys thank you so much I
really appreciate everything that you
guys are doing your your your truly
changing lives and your to be applauded
for that appreciate it so thank you
thank you my man I'm super excited for
the book to come out it comes out on
February 18th right favorite mastering
diabetes here it is what it looks like
Bowen camera don't pick it up wherever
you purchase books and I would assume
that you guys are gonna be out and about
talking about this quite a bit we are
you're gonna be doing our best yeah cool
we'll stay in touching and come back
talk to me again sometime thank you
really thank you so much for everything
I mean you are one of the most
inspirational human beings literally on
the planet thank you and I hope you know
that at this point that's a very
difficult thing I mean the number of
people that that I love the affirmation
and validation and I live for that so I
will feed out on that for a while
reserve the number of people I know that
have told me that that your podcast has
truly fundamentally changed our life is
gets countless at this point so I mean
for us to say we appreciate what you do
would be an understatement
you're a force for good and we totally
appreciate it thanks you guys
all right so beyond the book the best
place to get in touch with you guys
mastering diabetes.org it's and your
Instagram accounts mastering diabetes
and then- at mindful diabetic Ravi right
and you yours is a mango oriented one at
mango man nutrition tango malnutrition
sorry you guys peace out these plants
[Music]